bientôt huit heures et devant ce collège
de l'agglomération dijonnaise comme
partout un petit air de rentrée avec ces
retrouvailles et un peu d'appréhension
quand même c'est bien et c'est un peu
pénible parce qu'on va importer de
masquer des distances de sécurité ça va
être un super nier oui c'est une grande
journée après deux mois de confinement
ça fait bizarre
du côté des parents c'est pour beaucoup
le soulagement
c'est pas comme d'habitude mais c'est
vrai que ça va ça leur fait du bien
quand même mais ça que c'est dans des
conditions un peu stressante pour tout
le monde à commencer par la principale
du collège qui jusqu'au dernier moment à
une multitude de détails à régler
c'est la reprise aujourd'hui c'est une
première donc il faut être partout sur
tous les fronts avec toute l'équipe
ce collège a accueilli ce matin soixante
élèves de 6e sur 140 habituellement 40
d'entre eux des jeunes rond dans cette
cantine flambant neuf un par table on a
mobilisé tous nos agents bon certains
étaient en situation malades ou
impossible de venir
on a recruté 65 supplémentaires
contractuels donc on accueillera des
enfants dans de bonnes conditions
bon moi je voudrais bien savoir qui est
content de rentrer quand même les
collèges où on en est très heureux parce
que voir revenir les collégiens dans
leur établissement
renouer le lien avec l'école relouer
renault et du lien social retrouver des
repères et retrouver leurs enseignants
c'était absolument fondamental ici elle
est 6e auront cours les mardi et
vendredi les élèves de 5e seront
accueillis jeudi